rise and shine it's an spresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right grab your cup of coffee and
sip on today's message master the skill
of influence over to you Tony Robbins
also if you want to know what Tony and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link is in the
description below the fact that human
beings our strongest drive is the need
to stay consistent with how we define
ourselves so while you're in this
passionate state that's where you make
decisions so if you want to change your
life my friends you've got to change
your physiology and you got to change
your focus I believe that leadership is
really a skill of influence is the most
important skill that any human being can
master and I don't think of leadership
as a position I see it as a skill a tool
that all of us have to have in other
words the quality of your life I do
really believe comes down to your level
of leadership other people don't have to
follow you to be a leader but you have
to live life on your terms and the first
person you have to influence it yourself
you know whether you're fit or fat you
know whether your kids are out you know
on drugs or not it's who has more
influence the guy on the street corner
or you whether you're fit of fat is can
you influence your own hands your own
body your own mind to do what's
necessary so I think to be able to
influence the thoughts the feelings the
emotions and the actions of another
human being
that's what leadership is if you want to
influence someone this is the secret
weapon whoever is more confident wins
influences about transferring emotion
not logical facts you can have all the
best information data stats in the world
but unless I feel your emotional
commitment unless I feel your passion
unless I feel your certainty for the
argument that you are making you will
never sway me to action
whoever is more confident wins and it
works in business it works in life it
works with employees or worse with your
partner's your suppliers your investors
your husband or your wife whoever is
more confident wins here's why if I have
a fair level of confidence in my point
of view and I have any respect for you
and you are insanely confident in your
perspective that is different than mine
you will make me start to question my
own confidence in my point of view if
you told me that I couldn't look down on
my shirt and ask me what color I was
wearing I would say black and I'm pretty
confident that I'm wearing black because
I have a lot of black shirts in my
closet but if you said with absolute
confidence that I was not wearing a
black shirt and I felt your certainty it
would force me to look down just to make
sure and that's the moment that you have
somebody now we want to use our
influence for good to help people not to
trick people but the premise still
stains that whoever is more confident
wins your supreme confidence your
absolute belief in your side and your
point of view will make people question
their perspective okay so whoever is
more confident wins amazing how do you
actually do it I'm gonna share with you
three ways to boost your confidence so
that you can influence people better
number one is pattern recognition in
order to be confident in something you
need to know what you're talking about
and that comes by getting the exposure
and experience
consistently as quickly as possible and
so look at Tony Robbins he wanted to
help people he got involved in self-help
when he started his journey he read 700
books on the topic and through that
process of reading 700 different books
you start to see the same patterns come
up over and over and over and over again
and so you know what's coming you see
the behaviors you see it happening again
and again and again for YouTube I've
made 6000 videos I know a lot about what
happens on YouTube I have a high degree
of confidence in what I'm talking about
on YouTube because of the pattern
recognition because I've had the
exposure to it if you're talking about
keyboards I don't know you made a better
keyboard amazing what's the best
keyboard in the world I have no idea
whatever you want to be an expert at
whatever topic you want to have
influence over people on then you need
to do the work thing
gain the pattern recognition so if it's
leadership or as being an entrepreneur
or its sales or its marketing the way to
get it is to over expose yourself to it
watch every video read every book go to
every sales call go to every leadership
convention every meeting be involved get
your reps and over and over and over and
over and over again and the more you do
it the more you will get the pattern
recognition the more you will recognize
that huh this is happening again and
here it is happening again and here it
is happening again history repeats
itself but you have to be the student of
history in that field to understand what
the patterns look like number two is
raise the stakes you have to feel like
the words you are saying are important
you have to feel like what you are
saying is right and will help them and
if they don't do it they're gonna screw
themselves over for life like this is a
major decision your advice is important
you need to raise the stakes when I
first started giving advice to
entrepreneurs this was a really hard
thing for me I was afraid of ruffling
feathers I was afraid of offending
people and as a result the advice I gave
was right but there was no emotional
commitment there was no raising the
stakes I didn't make it important enough
because I was afraid of the reaction now
maybe that's because that's how my
parents raised me maybe because I'm an
introvert maybe because I'm a Canadian
whatever it is I was afraid to raise the
stakes on people and it was hurting them
and it was hurting me because I knew
what they needed to do but because I
didn't have the influence through
raising the stakes they never took
action on the advice then a single
moment with an entrepreneur changed my
perspective I was given advice to a
woman who had a business and she wanted
my advice and I helped her I gave her
what I thought was the right thing to do
but I didn't erase the stakes I didn't
have the emotional commitment behind the
advice even though I knew that it was
the right thing for her she did not take
the advice and as a result got screwed
over in her business she could have sold
her company she could have made a lot of
money she could have gone on done
something else and as a result she
didn't and she got screwed over and it's
easy to say that that's her fault but
it's my fault I take it as my fault
because I didn't do enough I could have
given more I could have tried harder I
could have had the emotional commitment
to the advice I could have raised the
stakes and if
still didn't take it I still didn't
influence her that's okay
but I didn't do the best of my abilities
recognize that you are the expert you
followed step number one you have the
pattern recognition you are the student
you are the historian you know more than
other people and that's not to rub it in
their faces say I know more than you but
if you know more than them and they are
ignorant and they are driving into a big
hole that's gonna screw them over for
life then it's your job to make them see
that hole with emotional intensity if
you feel like the words you are saying
are important than they will to remember
influence is an energy transfer game
it's an emotion transfer game not just a
logical one raise the stakes and number
three when you're 85% sure you're a
hundred percent sure this is a mantra
that I use for myself for my company for
the people that I'm training on my team
you will never ever ever ever ever be
100 percent sure never unless it has
already happened unless it has already
happened you will never be 100 percent
sure predicting the future you can be
close but you can never be a hundred
percent sure and so here's the thing
when you are talking to somebody and you
are trying to show them how this world
will play out how these sequences of
events are going to play out and how it
impacts them if you have any doubt then
they're gonna play on that doubt they're
gonna think whom this person has some
doubt and that's the only thing that
they are going to hear so what I like to
do is get at least 85% sure if I'm 85
percent sure that this is the correct
course of action then in my head I make
the shift I'm a hundred percent sure I
have absolute confidence because that is
what's gonna sway people if you are 85
percent sure and you don't go to a
hundred people will tag on to that 15
percent insecurity doubt fear
uncertainty and then are not going to
take your advice so if you're below 85%
certainty then you do research then you
ask questions then you try to do more
pattern recognition to try to figure out
how do I get myself to 85 percent
certainty but once you get to 85 you go
right to 100 and it doesn't mean that
you're not gonna make mistakes you will
still make some mistakes because there's
still that 50% chance of failure 50%
chance of doubt
insecurities it doesn't mean you won't
make mistakes but it's better to be
wrong 15 percent of the time and learn
from it then to be right 85 percent of
the time and people don't take action on
your vice because you're wishy-washy in
the delivery when you're 85 percent sure
you're a hundred percent sure now I've
got a special bonus clip for you that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know who is someone that you look up
to that you respect that when they speak
they influence you who is that person
and what have you learned from them
leave it down in the comments below I'm
looking forward to hearing what you have
to say
persuasion and anything so if you want
to persuade your children if you want to
persuade someone to take a look at your
faith if you want to persuade someone in
business if you want to persuade someone
to help you in anything or help them in
anything it's real simple for me
monster belief and so you can't transfer
to me that which you're not experiencing
yourself right so you can't give me a
people are we strike over the magic word
the magic clothes the magic this and
there are words you shouldn't shouldn't
use in persuasion no question about it
right there are think there are words
that are more effective in other words
and clearly to be successful in any
business you need to know what those
words are in your business but the best
persuaders the best motivators the best
speakers the best physicians the best
school teachers the best parents are
incredible persuaders and what they do
is they come from a monster place of
conviction and belief that they can
transfer you to because people respond
to energy much more than they do words
they respond to what they feel not what
they hear and see here and see a real
low level influencers energy spirit
transfer of energy is what people
respond to and so I'm cognizant all the
time of getting in a state of total
belief and certainty about what it is
that I'm gonna represent or speaking if
I'm speaking on stage about a particular
topic and then transferring that energy
into people and that seems generic or
hokey but it's actually what great
persuaders do in fact if you're listen
to this you think of anybody that you
know who's incredibly persuasive they
may have great words they probably do
but it's something you feel from them
right and that's the difference between
a great doctor and a so-so doctor great
doc says here's the prescription you're
out of here another one is they kind of
work or not another one you leave
they're feeling that you're going to be
healed selling you're in good hands you
feel their certainty you feel their
confidence saying when you hear a
speaker if you're buying real estate
from somebody but it's not just buying
things it's a great pastor in a church a
great person if you do TM who's taught
you TM it's there's certainty it's the
energy you feel and so for me it's
always getting to I have to really
believe what I'm saying I have to really
feel it Warren Buffett was doing the
speech in don't gates about me 10 years
ago and he was asked by a college
student what can we do as students to
make ourselves more valuable in the work
so you think Warren Buffett would say
learn how to pick stocks or investments
you know whatever he would say not what
he says he says go out and take a course
in sales and communication yeah he did
Dale Carnegie changed his lightning you
go now that point because he took they
said I took Dale Kearney changement
without that you know what he'd be
without that course yeah he'd be the
richest money manager in Omaha Nebraska
then no one ever heard of yeah Annie met
his wife that way the love is like
because without the ability to influence
and persuade yeah okay you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are
yeah raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that we believe
that people with passion and not one
drop of our self-worth depends on your
it's something serene if you guys like
this video I think you'll also like the
interest we did on Jordan Belfort
talking about influence and persuasion
the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there because you don't know how to
influence and persuade people you can't
get customers you can't get suppliers
you can't get people to join your team